boom day all right go make way to my
tricycle is yours but all good we're
live on the internet right now it's all
good buddy good to see you again
yeah some days it's for people so sub 9
Jimmy Neutron double Oh
the first man here Du Monde it's goodbye
Bob
oh and we got people on YouTube alright
the soy is gaming Joshua birth birth
Lord
we're just gonna give it a couple more
minutes to wait for everyone to tune in
and then we'll get into this rogue one
spoiler talk we'll start off talking and
I think we'll be good is if we just talk
about the movie for like without
spoilers for like a few minutes some
good just to like give our like let's
give our like general consensus suppers
and then we can go into we can go into
this you know maybe if you log in to my
channel real fast as I can probably
change all this alright guys give it a
couple minutes John say stuff to the
live audience please hi guys we're here
we just got out of Star Wars rogue or
rogue one a Star Wars yeah say it right
hey you know I mean robe or something
I like movies about a subtitle can you
guys hear us okay I need you guys to
chime in make sure we can you can hear
us alright
yeah you need to stand off to the side
during the first few minutes of the
livestream to make sure that the sound
and image quality up to arc lights high
standards yeah just let us know that if
we need to change anything
my name is John of the real regions with
me is great drag resource now I'm Jason
from movie source
sup guys what's up guys sorry this is
normally a lot more
I'm just livestream spoiler talk there
we go now with us now everyone will know
what's up when they're here so just so
you guys know if you ask questions and
[ __ ] you have to keep it road one
related you're not gonna go off and
answer some other [ __ ] we're gonna keep
it all Road when we live junkie it's
that bit closer to me yep tab bit closer
well squeeze in did Devon be leo was
subdued what's up okay so how many
people you got the audience you got
sixteen people on you now I've got fifty
one on YouTube alright guys if we sound
good everyone says so let's get talking
about stop Road one Star Wars store did
a long time coming
alright so I'll take this off so I'll
just give like you know two to three
sentences ago we talked first then we
can really go into details I really love
I love this movie honestly it might be
my second favorite Star Wars movie right
after Empire Strikes Back I was really
surprised as to how much I was in love
with all the characters in this film the
battle sequences were arguably the best
Star Wars has ever had
it was the most human the most the most
emotional for sure I really loved it
let's go next oh go uh yeah just saying
up what you said I'm not gonna go my
second fear I'd probably say third or
fourth favorite I still need to think
about that but the story was really
engaging like you said the characters
like you've really got invested in these
characters a lot and you really felt an
emotional stake for them and also you
felt the sense of danger just and so
many different scenes and during the
story and like I said these characters
are so freakin likable and the way they
they interact with each other it should
I love these characters jumps yeah I
don't love Star Wars in general I got on
Star Wars fanatic so going into these
movies is always a little bit of an
outsider experience for me I liked the
force awakens quite a bit I enjoy
and I think I enjoyed this one at least
on the first viewing more than that I
was written a lot more than the force
awakens honestly yeah because the thing
about all these movies for me is it
always takes a few weeks for me to
figure out what's gonna stick with me
but in terms of right now I had a
fantastic time launching this movie I
agree pretty much with everything he
said the the style the design the
different characters they put in I was
pretty much enthralled by everything and
not being a super huge Star Wars fan not
being superstar was literate I wasn't
lost by anything I got you know the
subtle nods and stuff so I I thought
they did it for a terrific job with this
what do you think Jason I really like
this movie a lot - I thought it started
out a little bit slow for me but like a
lot was going on our to do tracked it a
little bit second that got it got better
and better in the third act man I love
that just I mean especially the third
act were just so amazing all the battle
sequences some of the most beautiful
Star Wars shots I've ever seen really
good action and I like I like the force
awakens a lot too because it just looks
like current Star Wars it just looks
amazing but this movie out did it in the
visual the visuals so absolutely yes the
only problems I really have live within
about the first 20 or 30 minutes of the
film I felt like it was covering the
spanning so much in such a short amount
of time it was like a they had so much
to setup and all these characters is set
up in the world like the hands of the
world necessarily but they explore like
so many different plans a minute they
got a set up a lot of stuff to get the
main story on it's on its road because
most of this movie is about you know the
the Rebel Alliance going after the Death
Star plans that we got to get through
some [ __ ] to get to that story yeah the
first act
it is really immediate and you are
hopping from planet to planet to planet
and pretty much every scene yeah you let
they got that out of the way and early
on so they can just focus once the movie
got going to just focus on that story
yeah and again beeping me being you know
not huge about Star Wars my favorite
thing has always been the design
so for me the first egg didn't really
lose me that much because the places
they were going and the production
values and the fact that you could again
tell like there are lots of extras and
people in costumes and actual sets it
looks somewhat practical than CGI and
the father certain areas it felt to in
certain different shots you know that
going to spoil there's a really felt
like we were back in 1977 in a new hole
yeah I mean so they were delighted and a
lot of reminds a lot of canyons that we
got to see too that gave us that
reminder of you know that this is like
literally right before in your home so
you know I agree with you guys that the
first egg did have a lot to get through
but you know what it kept us rather
entertained and did a good job of
introducing these characters it's read
when they got to the planet general yeah
yeah that's when that's when we gun they
get to the Platte Jetta after they
recruit Jane I'm gonna record gin to
help them find her father's you know the
whole [ __ ] flies so when they go to
Jenna and then you meet Don en and what
are their character names you guys
remember their names
she rut and bass yeah yeah we a spell
bus right cheerin synthase so when you
meet cheering and Bazin like right away
Donny it helps just awesome to his first
line was his first line may the force be
you make force be with you what's he
like one day that's around when he's
like are you with the necklace or seeing
something to do he was saying stuff to
the crowd I recognize his voice right
away yeah and dude like the Donnie Yen
the whole time blew me away and I love
that they really did showcase um well
that it was sometimes you get like a
foreign actor international superstar
you put them in a movie and you're
usually put to waste you kind of wish
you had more than where they had a
little bit more time to shine don't
really utilize their talents
you got to see Donnie yen's acting
skills and you got to see his awesome
total arts be nice if there's if there's
one complaint I had about this I just
wanted more that stick but yeah I really
liked that fight scene that he has that
like main fight seeing a stormtroopers
Johnny and the staff is [ __ ] hot I
also thought Alan Tudyk as the voice of
k2s Oh that character liked it I love
the personality they gave to this
character like it was just you know some
robot that we didn't care like we really
got emotionally invested oh yeah robots
though and some of it some of the quips
that he was coming up with there this is
so important so is Claire the two
funniest characters and that's that's
part of the stuff that again that is
great about Star Wars that really shines
out in this movie is you have so many
different characters from so many
different places they all have vibrant
personalities and that's so much that
was my favorite thing about this movie
it was how much I loved the entire main
road one day yeah yeah I really didn't
find fault with anyone I didn't feel
like there was lacking of anyone or I
feel like anyone was overused I was like
I'm surprisingly and really surprised
the headlight I really like every single
character - - that also didn't really
have to do too much building over the
characters we actually get for now I
don't care about them so yeah this is a
war movie and that's that's a cool thing
to do with Star Wars especially because
the universe is so broad and so much of
it is built around this particular
situation zero and then on a battle it
literally is like making a war movie out
of a moment in history that's that's
what I felt like if felt like they were
teeth it was like watching a historical
movie weirdly about Star Wars because in
fact they didn't have like the opening
scroll and they just they still had that
similar shot like how they always have a
source of like a shadow up but I love
how they skip the scroll because it's
not really like Star Wars that much it's
not part of the Skywalker's Agins yeah
you know it's yeah it is a spin-off and
you feel it and that's part of again
something I really appreciated about
this is that it has a markedly Star Wars
but markedly different style I think
your there was it a terrific job
directness because it's at least on the
first pass it's really tight especially
once you know the story gets a chance to
breathe it's really tight with jumbling
all of its different characters and
stories and everything fits together
really nicely and it's captured with a
really zippy pace that never feels like
it's rushing too hard and never feels
like it's taking too long like it's it's
just immediate enough to make this
thrilling and also - I thought they did
a really good job of you know timing the
story of episode four and making it feel
authentic not forcing it down our throat
it wasn't a whole bunch of see how this
is time and see oh yeah it wasn't a [ __ ]
ton of that but there's much not you
know to where they get to Jenna they
have the one guy with some mentions of
other characters from Episode four so
definitely like I said totally there's a
lot of shots and scenes where you feel
like you're back in 1977 almost I love
that they captured a feeling the only
actor in the film who I kind of didn't
really care much worse performance or I
thought was a little over the top was
saw here at Forest Whitaker he was the
only one where I thought it was a little
bit forced they didn't feel well I
starboard every Star Wars movie has
there's a weird Star Wars acting like
nobody acts in any other movie like
doing a Star Wars movie and so like yeah
thing like that didn't bother because
I'm kind of used to that because if you
go back to the old movies there's a lot
of stiff but very committed acting
that's a funny way yeah but I'm thinking
like you're looking at this movie
everyone's amazing in this movie but
first what it like he's he's he's been
around a long time he's clearly kooky
like half his body is robot now I kind
of bought him as like kind of crazy you
know I know what he was going for it
just some of this didn't seem like
authentic to me it seemed a little bit
like he was forcing some of these
behaviors for me it's not like I did I
didn't like it but but I just didn't
really care that much I don't know you
didn't really hit that spot for me like
all the other characters did yeah I'll
meet you at overcommitted
okay because there's some stuff that's
like bring it back yeah I get that
his voice got it was a little over the
top and
and would you guys think of Diego Luna
casseon Kayson yeah good job I mean I
thought him in Felicity Jones had a good
chemistry to them and you know I thought
you did a good job providing in
situations you know where the states
felt hi and like just you know grabbing
that tension for him I thought he did a
great job
like I said the interactions between him
and k2s oh and him and Felicity Jones
character just like you really care for
those characters and you love those
interactions between yeah understood
enjoyed seeing the one moment where he's
about to pull the trigger to kill to
kill her dad basically and then he just
kind of realizes like no this is not the
running pose yeah the right thing to do
it kind of that's when he snapped for me
I thought it was gonna be like you know
Felicity Jones shows up to stop it right
before he pulls the trigger and they get
an argument and then there's some battle
breaks out like that like he had where
they had a moment where he clearly
chooses not to kill him they cut the
cliche moments in this movie to keep it
like that but he plays that moment
beautifully like there are a lot of that
but great little character nuances that
come out of both the script and the
performances and I I mean I really
enjoyed Diego Luna and I just thought it
was really cool that he gets to be the
male lead in a movie like this because
the movie like French Spanish is I think
he's it really does feel like a like a
scrappy team thrown together and like
you know you don't a lot of times
watching these movies you have
characters that sort of stand out from
each other as if they were like this guy
was always meant to be
you know a rebel fighter yeah like that
was he felt like just a guy who believed
in this situation and what they have
there's a point where they argue about
their like main motivations for fighting
or not fighting and why they chose to do
certain things like this is a really
real argument and even though Jin is our
like main lead character you get a lot
of different points of view about this
whole situation and that's yeah it's
nice to have a Star Wars movie that's
kind of a good allegory from life right
now because that theme of like how
how much do you stick to what you
believe is right you know I gotta say
this movie got me excited for others
spin-off so they're gonna do yeah this
is the most different totally
stylistically it's the most different
out of them all like I'm just so like I
was really invested doing all the
characters you know like well get to the
end do you know like what happens all
the characters I mean all you guys
pretty much know what happens but we'll
get to that later we're trying to save
the best boilers for a little bit later
but going over some other characters I
really did like baseball this a lot yeah
when James character John when John look
they say that gunner guy yeah such a
great balance between today and I love
that love that you never find out why
are these together yeah you never find
out what you can feel like history said
they're like guardians of the temple or
something that was that's Troy has a
totally different passive protective he
felt over him - yes that's like we're
that history that you talked about like
comes in like because like this guy like
any any moment where there's a danger is
gonna happen like this guy takes out his
machine gun and helps tiny and so I mean
also if sorry go ahead John oh no it's
just nice for those things because the
characters don't become invincible
that's what they do it's like it's that
thing of one little push of belief or
perseverance can get that one crucial
moment - about yeah and so the way they
learn from each other especially with
you know when he takes on sure it's
mantra you know you know that one last
moment like terrific you know like
they're they're interplay between enjoy
this great yeah I thought they were
perfectly well-balanced I'm glad they're
both Asian actors always it was like two
solid Asian actors and Lee was like my
token agent care from the team in the
diverse cast and the way they're all
sent like on a crazy kamikaze mission
had a lot of resemblances and feelings
of aliens you know a good thing for me I
mean because like that whole team was a
bunch of bad guys right you know I mean
and just like that whole feeling if
they're going into a crazy suicidal
mission you know [ __ ] bad shits about to
happen and you're
invested in these characters not a bad
thing I felt like though that these
characters means reading frames and
aliens for a second I thought that they
were more although there's more
emotional depth to them absolute little
context in them like the character I
really like this guy a lot bode Luc
Lyssa reason I was so happy
yeah I had no idea he was in this I
thought he was he was one of my favorite
surprises of yeah like he's he he was
great at Nightcrawler and stuff like
that that's right that's right
and so I mean by these characters that
each wanted them on the team does an
amazing job like even a character like
Rizzo Mons character might have gotten
kind of put in the backburner a little
bit but he they met they gave just the
right amount of screen time he's
definitely not the most focused on
character but he's there just enough to
feel like his role really fulfills an
entire purpose and does have its own
heart as well and in terms of the
villains Ben Mendelsohn is forcing
training I thought it was was ready yeah
I thought he was so good and I was like
what she's just a human being he was
human bad guy yeah that's right pitched
for that role because he is like
dastardly the way the Star Wars generals
harvest not you know cranked up to 11
like he is yeah your she's a formidable
imposing presence on screen even when
his operations threatened like he does a
fantastic job ya know and when he's
talking to Grand Moff Tarkin you buy
that you buy when he's when he's uh you
know trying to be like a amore posing on
him rather than me being more cowardly
like a lot of inferior officers so you
buy that because Ben Mendelsohn is very
menacing in this performance and who was
a who's the actor that's got the address
and little brother they brought back for
most of the movie grand monster yeah
yeah yeah and the cushion it was the
actor that like
what's his name Creighton general Draven
is the character is it they reveal that
to everyone that he was gonna be here
Grand Moff Tarkin yeah I mean they
didn't reveal it I just in one of the
trailers I noticed from one of the shots
that had to kind of look like him he
does a very noticeable recognizable head
can I do right away from the show that
you shop without a back the back cushion
what's that character's name this is
general Draven no it's grandma oh that's
why everyone's saying they think Tarpons
use a little too much okay cool Oh Mike
real quick we got bars for vote two one
Jeff Emilio
those are number one fans on you now
right now and so they're my favorites I
play favoritism over subscribers all the
time anyway yeah yeah so I want to talk
about that battle sequence that Jenna
that was that battle sequence it took
place it wasn't that long but once it
started happening I started really
understanding what this movie is gonna
be like yeah because it's like this it's
like a war zone battle sequence it felt
like a scene in like a war territory in
like Afghanistan if you watching film if
it felt surprisingly real which I loved
about it was like it's all space
technology they're dealing with this is
Star Wars or stormtroopers there but
this feels like this is how it would
probably really go down amongst the
rebels and the Imperial Army versing
each other yeah yes I think they towed
the they added a certain naturalistic
realistic quality the movie I won't say
like they made it realistic because like
that would be really gruesome but like I
think that they did high blood and stuff
but but they do go out of the way say it
realistic for a star
there was a you know it is a bit more
handheld there are a bit more of those
like you know panning around and racking
the stuff shots and everything and yeah
there is a quality to this movie has I
think enhances the war scenes especially
where you really do feel like so many of
the scenes are people going to [ __ ] what
do we do next and then a game of chance
comes in they address it late but you
know everything feels like each scene is
led leads to a chance and here's you
know kind of Alba's situation grows and
that does make especially the military
maneuvers and stuff feel very real when
stuff goes wrong it feels that much more
real and with the Star Wars franchise
economy know or just keep rebuilding and
making bigger Death Star's and change
yeah this was the first movie where I
really truly felt the fear of the Death
Star and then just well no I mean but
that makes sense because like they're
just finishing this new out of the
packaging and they're like let's let's
first a quick demo yeah let's not call
massive attention and that's the thing
is like this movie in some ways makes
the Death Star smaller and yet it's that
much scarier because when they pull you
it's the same thing here in other words
did with Godzilla where when they put
you on the ground and you need to watch
this from a perspective that really
makes it yeah the impact hit we're Wow
they don't really destroy they killed
tons of people in this city they lay a
city and it looks like a nuclear plume
yeah yeah that was a great sequence it
was a great I thought there was a really
nice I thought I liked the use of CGI in
this movie yeah I like what's really
noticeable no I
it's because like I don't know Gareth
Edwards a cinematographer is but the way
the cinematography blends with the the
rest of everything else it just makes it
look that much more real which I I never
got pulled out things like it was the it
was the character Act
what's the character's name again
general but grand moff tarkin general
grand mark target I said it's grandma
it's a scream off general grand moff
tarkin
grandmother's grandmothe target well I
keep saying general for some reason
grandpa Star Wars fans are gonna Creek
you for the abbot's
a grand moff tarkin i at first i did
notice a little bit of this each other
it wasn't very long until i just thought
yeah that was really cool thanks
pretty crazy they brought him back it's
pretty good saying that might be the
best I've seen that effects haven't
showed up my mind actually look like
great through that scene sort of skip
and I was like yeah it's a Peter Cushing
day yeah that particular effect once you
realize he's dead you have to see it
like you'll find where the the edges
aren't stuff but it is really good like
they that I've seen that effect I'd also
that effect look awkward and it doesn't
yeah and also to not only did they get
the face in the CGI look really good
with the voice he sounded lame I'm like
grand moff tarkin from a new hope so I
like how they captured that bad voice
where it sounded like Peter Cushing from
a new hope so if there were guys who's
like hold job is to come in and like a
TR for people when they can't so I'm
sure somebody out there got a real lucky
with their diet like pushing in Britain
yeah what do you guys think of gallon
Erza Mads Mikkelsen
I mean I love that actor I wish she was
in this movie just a little bit more cuz
I just like I said I love everything
that he's in but he was good at while he
was in it I mean he he did his job I was
just disappointed he wasn't mind bending
the dead star and yeah like that that
would have been a little more but no
just a DJ's point it would have been
nicer
haven't been there more but again I
understand there's so much stuff ya know
a lot of characters yes so I didn't
bother me too much that they didn't have
him in the film war I mean we were meant
to feel very sympathetic for this
character I just I thought you did a
great job you know of making you care
for him with the limited time you did
get in the film well yeah and I think
that's kind of a classy way to handle
that cuz it's like that character is
kind of only as much as it needs to be
and it doesn't just cram more mads
action just because like I could have
seen when Jin sees the hologram message
yeah started getting to go she played
that beautifully yeah she played that
wonderfully sweet mom like buy into but
yeah if she did I did think the scene
like when they're at the base and like
he dies right when she sees him was a
little bit cliche but the scene itself
was pretty good so I can't get on it too
hard but I'm like okay he's really gonna
die like right when we see each other
for the first time just like yeah yeah
but those are one of they were like
cliche I was like okay but but other
than that he was really good I just
really loved how this movie does put you
in that realm of being part of the
resist because you can look at the other
Star Wars movies like yes Leia Luke on
they're all technically a part of the
resistance but you don't really focus on
like the whole scope of like yeah say
that - like I love how this movie
actually portrays like the ha almost the
height of the Empire like oh yeah troll
you really feel like their presence we
the end of universe not only that the
focus is not a as you said on those
three main characters you've got an
array of different characters and
obviously jyn erso is the main character
but it almost didn't feel like it's just
absolutely focused on her because we got
all these different extravagant
personalities and great characters so I
thought they did a great job just
blending them all together one and I
mean I think that's a credit at least as
far as I've experienced with other films
I think that's a credit to Garrett that
works all across this movie is like
everything has scope and you have a
really good sense for you know where the
the rebellion is at where the Empire
that you know the the scale of the
destruction like everything has a scale
right down just when they walk off shots
like the cinematography well then lock
off shots on the side of a spaceship
coming right out of warp speed you know
hyperdrive like and you like lurch to a
halt and you see the the expanse of you
know ships approaching like those made
of those moments that much more later on
the script to like after after what's
Mads Mikkelsen dies they're back on the
ship
and gin is confronting Diego Luna the
dialogue they had back and forth and I
remember like happened big and no going
off in my head what she's like you might
as well be a stormtrooper she says
something like that the way that
dialogue was done I loved how I was like
I really bought the realism behind this
science fiction Star Wars dialogue me I
felt the effect of what that meant in
that moment it wasn't just like actors
saying cool Star Wars lines like I
really felt the emotional impact of her
saying that no I agree no sorry gotta
jump
oh no that's a nice back-and-forth
conversation especially as like the
thematic stuff in this movie goes
because they don't just have a
conversation and it's solved you know
it's like gin and cassia both leave the
room with their ideas and it is sort of
a central element of this movie is that
debate over you know when do you take
action how much you know actually you
take and you know how much do you let
your moral compass guiding that process
versus you know listening to the
structure and and they played that out
like those character moments I think a
lesser movie would have just told you
its message and leg room and they didn't
do that which is real nice and also play
off the script a little bit to me Greg
we're kind of discussing a little while
back when watch some of the trailers
work out
I'm at least for me I was worried some
of the lines were coming off a little
cheesy like this is a rebellion I
rebelled like I was yeah it wasn't even
in the movie so I thought they did a
good job of like that getting over my
fear of some of the lines playing off as
cheesy like you said like just that line
where she's talking to diego luna's
character like it felt so ya know in a
Star Wars film you know
sci-fi/fantasy so like I thought the
script was really well done and I
thought a lot of the way the actors you
know did their lines just really really
convinced and for a movie without Jetta
so going lightsaber you see his Vader's
at the end yeah booth at Chad yeah we
will talk in a little bit exploit these
stills you get a strong sense of the
force especially I mean Tommy not
everyone talks about like yeah Donnie
Yen is the main reason you get this is
with me but it isn't over all and you
still get that presence I'm just like I
love that well the first human being
Star Wars belt so real they did really
well in that even fleshes out the world
because again it's cool to see the
concept of the force from a different
perspective because you look at Donnie
yen's character and you're like I don't
know if this guy's actually imbued with
you know the power of the force but the
belief and I notice that it's brought
him it does do something like the force
feels like a presence that exists in the
universe even if you're not so he was
like it feels like they know people do
need to believe it yeah like a high that
hot is that higher kind of love yeah I
think I thought it was awesome it is
like a spiritual concept and it comes
across that way in this movie is the
exam and the other ones you see people
like yeah but in this it feels like you
know one of the mysteries of the
universe exactly exactly so Darth Vader
i I do hope that like by the time he
came in I wasn't what was sitting
watching this film going on this dark
favorite image okay what do you showed
up I was like yes but not going like not
letting the fog reveal yeah yeah I feel
like this this movie benefits from a lot
of classic stuff that was there in the
original Star Wars and is nice to see
them using as they continue it because
again even little moments like that you
have a lot of again the design and the
practical effects of the miniatures all
that but that moment were the two drains
that's just a glimpse of this geeky
thing inside like cut me leave most your
best
it's really effective that way like it
yeah
it really made me imagine you know I
also thought they did a good the way
they used the character in the amount of
time that they use they activated over
you I mean just they easily could have
overuse this character and forced it
down our throats which would have been a
bad thing to you can never get too much
of a derp but I mean I thought they used
I thought they use him really
appropriately in this film and just did
a good job tying together back to New
Hope yeah I mean the Vator the Batum
little dialogue scene with Brennan
cranek was lost it was really good and
they did go back to the tribute of like
when he starts choking em death which is
really in style yeah Mandelson
awesome he off he's a very layered
villain in this movie he's not to do you
mind up against banging got a face mask
yeah we see we see you talk to Bader
there is this you can see this layers of
this guy who's like I gotta be strong
but almost everybody's talking with the
actor who's there and Mokhtar yeah and
you see this guy who really does want
hit like what's owed to him you've got
to respect he wants recognition
absolutely but you it's like a desire
that we all can really do nothing like I
was really impressed by that
anyway it's not more for words get
somewhere just go and talk for a while
okay so the where's the last where's the
planet the final one is your Beach plan
computer I'll go on Wikipedia well you
listen is the beaches of Normandy right
yeah well you check that Danny Unchained
I knew one donated 200 bars eyes dude
you have unchain my heart that is a song
by Steve Eagar quote me on that I want
you to tell people that I believe that's
a song for Stevie Wonder
anyway alright and then we'll answer
some questions after we're done coupling
our spoilers that we know we want to
talk about off the top of our head scarf
I call scarf so the back of that beach
planning on John Fox is over New York we
shot I love that I love the way the
whole like infiltrations like the set up
to the big battle when there's like we
just got there and then [ __ ] just
starting don't want banana it's like
they loved that they set up the traps
they set up the bottles called
scare scare it is that the bombs I love
oh I not man Mandelson it's like Renick
like I love that shall read you just see
it from like his perspective from so
yeah [ __ ] is going be most all the time
yeah that's part of the magic is it
really does feel real because you're
always the most part from a human point
of view at least you have a fans point
and like you were saying to the shots of
like reminding me from Godzilla like
when you see them on the ground looking
at these 8080 walkers are there
different kind I heard they're not
exactly that like they're different
versions very similar yeah but that was
amazing I was amazing and I'd love that
oh they didn't start too much like prior
to them going there and then agreed to
go on this mission together to get the
Death Star plans I love that they only
have like one scene where you know the
rebellion was like no we can't do this
and it's not like forever they're not
losing hope and despair like they
repeatedly got to the next scene with
Diego Luna earning his Redemption by or
like making peace with her by saying
like we're gonna help you off this
mission we believe in you and it did
make the mission feel that much more
personal which I really appreciate this
was more than alliance needs this
you guys are assigned like they were
doing it when no
the Alliance are supporting them
business which made it that much more
effective then anyway back to that
battle sequence though everyone gets a
chance to shine everyone gets a chance
to do great stuff in that moment
yeah the cutting of that of that whole
entire sequence oh wow he'll to all over
the places felt very focused Wow in so
many different places and that's hard
man to balance time because so many a
lot of stuff is happening in that
especially on spirit plate and the way
they oscillate between the different
characters like nobody felt that they
were wait for too long and nobody felt
like they were you know slighted like
way to look at here sometimes too like
this needs to happen okay cut away a
little bit and you're right back yeah
and like how are we gonna make this
happen
you got the guys on the beach and then
you got the pilot trying to do his thing
like and I love that that means they
didn't just cut away from him for a long
time before he had to like try to help
upload this information like he was
smart with like saying like I see rebels
over here like he was lying to them and
then when the rebellion comes in I love
that without it being so obvious in our
face like what like who's the character
that brought back the lady in the Ryloth
month yeah yeah what she is informed
that they're they're just like very tiny
kind of smile yeah so subtle but you're
like that's it that's what I call we're
ready to do this and I love I still felt
that spirit I felt that spirit of the
rebellion Danny together like funny we
all said no or we're in this now we're
coming together to do this so then you
have this Beach battle you got Jen and
Diego Luna like trying to get the Death
Star plans and then you got the Space
wars going on it was [ __ ] awesome
because they're just beautiful yeah I'm
so good this is one of the best
structured most beautifully shot battles
I've ever seen in a Star Wars it was the
best I'm going to say this is my
favorite act of any Star Wars yeah it
might be a stretch to say that but I'm
sticking with it hey miss for now
you know it's just just the fresh off of
that first appeal yeah that's a part of
it this movie in an effortless kind of
way gives you most everything you could
want the Star Wars movie at least for my
head
something I was going to say earlier
like I felt with episode 7 they were
just trying so hard to be like it's a
Star Wars loving Star Wars on business
thought we're just more generic like
that was more effortless and this is not
the try selected which is more this is
surprising because I felt like force
awakens played even more to our
nostalgia yeah like they're like this is
love this this is right before Episode
four again I didn't feel like they were
Oh like voting in so much only artist
Oliver
yeah well this for me the difference
between this first wake it's like force
awakens is very I don't know if
respectful is the exact word I'm looking
for but it's it's respectful because
that really had the this sort of had to
bear the brunt of okay we're trusting
you yeah yeah
after three of these so like that movie
has it does do its own thing to just
bring some fun but it is respectful and
this movie feels fearless like this yeah
this movie just charges forward like
here's what our Star Wars looks like
we're doing I'm gonna go out on a limb
and say this is the best prequel ever
give me living there
yeah I mean this is I think it's a good
idea to keep Star Wars fresh to make a
movie about the people who fight the
battles not just the people who won the
war yeah because that's yummy
we have the first it is just a different
kind of story it's crazy because when I
first heard that they were doing this I
was like what the [ __ ] is the point of
this movie we're just like it sounds
like such a way to cash it right now we
all know they're gonna succeed and get
the Death Star plans is ridiculous but
yet it felt like such an Asst after I
was done watching I was like this feels
so essential to the full experience of
the entire film can you know I was
wildly impressed and I I'm so glad a lot
of people were predicting like they
can't actually kill off everyone because
we these are characters of getting to
franchise and make toys out of it we
need merchandise they're not gonna buy
toys or people who aren't dead but they
killed off everything I love that's like
an old-school movie that
let's go movie I love the way that they
gave every single character at their
moment yeah and it happens for like turn
out kind of not all at once it happened
throughout the whole I won got a good
death
yeah like da ya gotta do his name word
you really is honing in on the force
allowing horse [ __ ] with me home
with the force is gonna be that's going
to be a shirt yes right the only thing
that would have made I mean again didn't
ruin the story or anything but just from
an action perspective I just wish we
could have seen Donnie and fight Darth
Vader that would that would have been
sweet way you know when they inevitably
remake episode 1 Johnny and cuz I'm like
there you go John brought up a great
point after the movie was done because
he was talking about k2s those death and
he was telling me something that like
just clicked right away from me like
yeah that's how I felt was like you know
[Music]
k2s o died it was that feeling of like
I'm actually it was one of those like
they all died but it was a rare feeling
of like well I'm gonna miss these guys
they're actually all dead but I thought
it was great for the story they all died
I'm happy that I'm sad I'm not gonna see
so yeah because that's something that I
don't get to do a lot especially at
blockbusters they want you to care so
hard I think is great about this movie
now I got love and they killed them all
and just like the fact that Ben
Mendelsohn who dies from the Death Star
as well and that that mom likes the
faculty and like they roughly on the
opening scold episode for I don't know
if any of this was the any of George
Lucas's original idea they were what how
the rebels got deaths
plans the first place but they did make
it very meaningful you make you feel it
makes you feel like that sentence was
just a throwaway line for something epic
that man is roll but yeah like yeah Jin
sends them the message the Death Star
plans and then when they're on the beach
I know they held hands being kiss right
so glad yes yes well you can do it
anyway like how the idea sure we just do
it they're about to die but you can so
they felt something for it yeah yeah
you're like a physical closeness in
their body language that you know for
this movie and for what they show you
yeah to people who [ __ ] went through
hell and did it yeah yeah like they're
clothed like there's something that Bram
physically close together it's really
kind of beautiful in that city and also
they're arcs were like really complete
like they did something for the good of
the rebellion you know they did they
sacrifice they were gonna die well
they're from different sides
yeah yes and they meet you know at the
victory annex yeah I mean like now the
moment everyone and spite the whole
story the moment I saw the Darth Vader
[ __ ] up a bunch it was like thirty
seconds but it was the mighty walk as
Louie could have sucked and been
horrible and if we had that dark fairy
30 seconds I would have said you know
what the movies suck at least we got to
see that amazing 30 second cut right
there but no the fact that it was a
great story and we were so invested at
this point then we got to see Darth
Vader doing what we know that he's to do
in his prime as Darth Vader it was
freaking of me I yeah it was it was one
of the it's not like a necessary scene
at all but it's so I think it is
necessary because it does at least
remind you of just how yeah the first
time you see me like bad boy just I know
but at the same time I they just look
back on the movie and
my technically Vader doesn't really need
to be in this movie he technically
doesn't need to be we all known are
being followed but if he wasn't wasn't
would be involved if it wasn't the movie
yeah I feel like we're stay there I'm
just saying like you take out Vader
scenes the movie doesn't oh yeah shocker
it doesn't change but I don't know I
think some of the time you come in like
is that's kind of why I loved invaders
yeah I do but I think they work outside
of just being oh cool Vader's back like
I think he does yeah you don't need
those scenes for the movie to make sense
necessarily but I think if you took them
out it would take something with them
and what I will say though about that
Vader fight because I I did think like
that was the best beat White's wife
every other they've never seen Vader
like I never like holy crap like that
moment worked just the rufio he throws
the one guy on the ceiling perfectly for
you this was one of those sci-fi epic
action movies that really was about
characters at the centerpiece yeah but
the action is still like mind blown and
that's what I want to be yeah well yeah
and I mean this is the kind of again
like the great thing about making it a
war movie or you know that'll do B is
that that's the kind of story where you
part of it as you learn from your
character's art by the way they behave
you know because a lot of movies take
place in normal life for these people or
their vast expanses of just like kind of
days and this is like a very immediate
situation which everybody has to band
together right now and act and and the
way the script develops its characters
just through their action makes them
feel that much more like yeah yeah so
you don't even need hunters of like
here's a picture I thought it was a
great ending actually you know I gotta
take back all that because like if they
didn't have that bigger part it would
have like how much the effect on Vader
really
that's Bader's prior moment to what we
see in him and episode yes yes we should
that doesn't fall in your scene how much
it affects him that I was going to go
with her [ __ ] everyone I'm not sending
in my troops to go do it for me and
that's the thing that partly that makes
this situation important is this guy
this situation gets out of hand enough
that it needs to involve even just for a
minute or two
Darvish yeah this got all the way up to
upper upper upper management what do you
guys think of Leia I want you okay I'm
gonna give the unpopular opinion it was
really cool to see here and and she
looked just like she didn't new hope but
the face was a little CGI for me
personally but again it was really cool
to see you know just that that version
of her from the 1977 but it did stand
out Jonathan didn't bother be a boy yeah
no question that the Peter Cushing one
was perfect this one was a little CGI I
would have just prefer to go to the back
absolutely I would I would ago that's
actually what I thought they were gonna
do I mean I thought like when she said
hope significant if you're gonna give
her a line there you go you found the
perfect there's a last name the next
movie I would have cut to the hologram
when they're watching
when Vader said prepare to board
actually thought them he was like
porting the ship like the captain
intuition selection yeah the line was
good I liked seeing Leia in there I just
it just took me a for a second out of it
because the face was Lucy time but like
I said the Peter Cushing one was perfect
for me personally I'm gonna backtrack
significantly but you know the battle
sequence it let's go back you know when
this when the spaceship start appearing
yeah hyperspeed that was awesome the POV
that was so cool it's a different
perspective of how they've seen this
before so many so many great shots in
this would be 100 particular stops me is
when they destroyed Jenna I guess the
shot like the explosion and then it just
pans up like to the Death Star and then
you see it from the desktop perspective
just see the Death Star like on the
horizon
I just made it feel even bigger than it
already is
all right guys start asking your
questions we'll start answering some
questions being more specific towards
your actual questions here let's see if
there's any that came from you're going
to get several coming in right now
doo doo doo just waiting just wait Oh
Elsa - we get I'm gonna do Twitter on
this pander center to make my life
easier together
another thing I noticed too with the
music a little bit like they didn't have
a lot of the actual Star Wars themes but
they were still at like in that sink you
think like oh it's not it sounds similar
everything six weeks to write the music
and I thought hey guys I'm super close
to the camera today just to read some
quick questions okay um let's see here
kg two seven nine four says rank your
Star Wars movies for the road one that
this may be partially cuz I've just seen
it but I probably would have to put it
second or third I would say second for
me okay right after we turn our rankings
right over we don't have to do all them
yes works for you but I'd say either
third or fourth because Empire Strikes
Back is definitely number one yeah I'd
say it's really close I mean I have to
watch it another time or two but do open
it new hope again is just so high on the
high out there for me it's it's pretty
close I'd say third or fourth River fo
for said late jump or if you rent road
one right right now just stop seeing the
movie so that's how I guess better than
forcefully and I think it's always
Star Wars always and they enjoy it at
I'm so late yeah and I like force
awakens but I think this was better yeah
I think I would want to watch this again
before I want to watch force awakens new
man this this movie done did I feel like
I noticed when I was watching like oh I
definitely just not mind watching this
again
this movie also did that not a lot of
Star Wars movies do I mean obviously
these characters are in dangerous
situations a lot of these movies but I
really felt a sense of danger for these
characters obviously we know the outcome
of course where they're gonna get this
the plans of the best but again what you
fear for their life you're better light
on this like really you really do when
it sets up this tone that like things
could go wrong you know like things
anything can happen
there's a lot of chance but it adds the
emotional death and the impact is you
know these characters Jay Thomas says
you think 10 tip for ivy yeah Ben Ford
oh my bad yeah yeah yeah the nice miss
what Oh bail are gone are you talking
about Senator Bail Organa are you
talking about the plan again for which
one week I was sad tangent for he says
you've been tented for I lost the
question to ask Santa for went straight
from the battle on scarf scarf straight
to tattooing to deploy are to beat you
to get to thank Adobe well yeah I mean
we saw captain and Toby ship going up
and did his Darth Vader was in pursuit
so I would assume and we do see Leia
wearing literally the same thing she
wearing in a new hope when she gives art
to the plan so I'm assuming a new hope
is literally five minutes or literally a
day after this that battle so yes I
would say yes to that question
Kyler's go said they asked a question
receipt for your video and are too easy
what really involved reuse fairly
obviously not they only have one it was
not reference that is the one like just
legit ask Andy yeah oh look what's them
but I'm happening yeah buddy one for one
sighs I'm so like c-3po isn't every
single movie now and II do still in
every single one and this one in
particular I think it was nice for proxy
would say but it didn't feel like you
know like I want to Avengers movies
where it's like oh that guy's in town
it's like oh they're here and I think
you can probably triangulate well cuz
they're there at the base for that to go
up on the ship for they've done the play
yeah that's what it's literally about to
say just keep sorry still okay thanks
man
it keeps the continuity and also to see
somebody injection yeah what they said
to nickname to forever to ask that you
think they tried too hard for comic
relief of key to that so I know because
they always like the droids always have
their own personality yeah you know and
I think that's again one of the cool
things about the Star Wars universe is
like he's my favorite Roy there's yeah
I've ever joined to say what he really
is
let me know I love r2d2 just because
he's like especially I think episode one
where he where he's like on the ship and
doing all that stuff I thought that was
a bad attack for him but k2 was just
hopeful area and I love that dry humor
that he had oh you like our - the way
you like like a really smart dog yeah
you like he's not you can't with a
engage of as much as going beeps and
stuff so like you're actually on you can
really connect with the agent more yeah
I was I would say okay - SS my favorite
robot yeah I love them he was like it
was like a better blend of like BBA and
you know cuz I see Dupree c-3po is a
very specific personality - its c-3po I
was like you know you're you're fussy
whereas you know K - it's like not only
was came to us so fun to use a bad ass
doing stuff like that
so like it's something the one shot that
we have where he catches a grenade and
just the road like other questions you
guys watch Star Wars rebels now I know
that's that we a cubits rogue one
related I don't watch rebels just saying
I know but what was the worst thing
about the movie I see some sometimes it
was a little predictable for me like
when Diego Ludo fell down in the the
scene with chronic I knew and meet like
the second he fell down at the end I
knew that
immediately gonna come to the rescue and
save a gin from Freddie
so I'd say some sometimes the thumb was
a little predictable in certain areas
but it didn't it didn't bother me
because I mean what else were they
supposed to do there so I mean yeah I
mean worse I can't really think of like
the worst part the only thing that kind
of sway to go every favorite who's the
worst it was offensive it just like
wasn't yeah I really just thought the
editing and pacing of like the first 20
30 minutes oh that's the if I ever see
like that yeah we're smart I guess that
would be the worst terrible just a
little over stuff in the beginning like
I'm so hard to keep track of okay this
guy's at this point in this case at this
point yeah what about you Jay well I'm
part of me I don't know if I would wish
for this movies be a tad longer because
I did feel that during the the first act
to I was like yeah we sure going a whole
lot Lisa's right a real hurry so yeah I
might have expanded that but the thing
is like this movie feels like a lot of
stuff happened and it didn't really feel
like it to our like I'm like a full-time
you know there's the pacing was so yes
so I don't know there's nothing that is
like bad yeah I think that movie where
he comes back and like that is real
convenient in a movie work convened so
it doesn't happen as much so it stands
out but tricky kids 73 a spur I mean we
mention this in the very beginning what
not as many people were tuned in so
mentioned again yes did it bother you
okay well I'm gonna remember your
question tricky kid before I forget my
Camille axe asked favorite line in the
movie evilly when Donny are you kidding
me to us so I guess that was the best
line by far oh yeah wasn't when the
pilot is talking about how they'll be
stranded in space when he's like what do
you say Jim like I'll fight with you or
something
because yeah I'll fight with you because
you told me to yeah oh hey I got one the
part where she shoots one of the Droid
robots and he's like did you know that
was like yes yes that was amazing I also
like the line but Vader had when he was
talking to critic I forget a lot exactly
but when I trees choking me let's go
he's like don't let your quest for power
like you know I forget the line exactly
but I just remember that line real quick
they're a tricky kid we brought this up
earlier as did Bobby there was no title
crawl movie no no not at all I thought I
actually liked it and I thought that
makes this more special and more
immediate and a blue font the trails off
this is great welcome yeah they have to
have a locker I'm gonna galaxy far far
away I'm expecting to crawl but then
it's like BAM no movie your title crawl
is watching episode three and four and
it seems like the pieces together great
I know crawl is just the first day
because it's like that dish it you would
have read about and they just showed
it's not a lie would have been it's nice
when you get it because it amps you up
and gets you ready for Star Wars but
again this is even though it is
connected in certain ways obviously it's
right before a new hope it is its own
separate thing in terms of it's not
telling the Skywalker saga so I think
they wanted to get away huh hey this is
not the sequel to Episode eight this is
totally a different timeline we're being
our own separate entity than from the
Skywalker Saga storylines Zarina her
quote was don't choke on your
aspirations we had a really badass long
I love that I got Jane I love that they
got James Earl Jones back to do them
always hi obviously if I'm saying they
might not mean of course he's voicing in
rebels so obviously you knew he was
going do from that so that was great
yeah yeah and we didn't get a new ruling
so school the corn Christian neurons he
asked he asked about rebels because he
said you see the chopper cameo general
syndulla
mentions the co [ __ ] I didn't I did not
notice that I did hear that there were a
few references from yes
I I think I could be totally wrong but I
think maybe it's forced Whitaker's
character on rebels I recommend wrong
I'm not sure did you guys notice that
Sebastian shake pointed out so you're
gonna say the best how do you know how
did you feel that they that they did see
they CGI the original pilot spaces from
a new hope I don't think those were
stock footage shot yeah yeah w1 that'll
put you in this time I thought it was
cool that we got to see the battle
before their final battle of fighting
the Death Star on ya before so it was
supposed to wow these guys obviously we
knew they were involved in bounce but we
got to now first and see the battles
that they were involved in so it was
cool to just add that little aspect of
it I'm just starting on female pilots
too
I just thought it was cool that for the
Star Wars fanatics just given these
little oh yes boy I don't get them they
get the bar guys and tattooing like I
don't like you either than the art you
do you know there's so many things that
make Star Wars fans happy absolutely
that almost feels like a wish list thing
like if you're lucky enough to get to
direct a Star Wars movie like well what
fits into mine oh I'll take those guys
yeah and also too I mean I thought when
we were in soccer it was a little his
little home area I thought that it kind
of reminded me obviously the Cantina
scene I liked the music that was going
on there to even see the little dancer
yeah exactly the hologram yeah yeah that
was cool the one from Jabba's palace
yeah yeah
- name two nicknames took forever said
how loud was your theater and I was very
quiet I was actually surprised by how
quiet are people out there one thing is
because at the very beginning someone
was doing oh yeah sure they collapse at
the very beginning but nothing for when
Phaedra movements on water to cheer and
so I was like I feel like
I was kind of like I guess yeah like I
love baby that was the worst part of the
movie for me is not having like it's
like jacked about the experience yeah
make something so made it a bit use
people's a lot of it was done oh yeah
rap like it was still good crowd one
sometimes you get those movie crowds or
everyone just rig the whole time you're
like sure I want to hear what the talkie
oh that's true like I remember it been
just really quick
two seconds going off-topic mmm I saw
vendors the first two times and Hulk is
throwing around Loki because the crab
design is so into it so loud you
couldn't hear low-key like squirming and
yeah exactly so but it should be good
yeah yeah I agree it would have been a
little cooler to have the audience be a
little more interactive in the film what
okay Camille access what character would
you who would you choose I mean no like
it seems like most of us believe it's
Kate to us oh and Donny done yeah stand
out the most
who would you say if you have to narrow
down to one what's the best character
let me that stand out there yeah but I
love coming out and you know it was
close I don't know if he sees my life
number one favorite here but I didn't
really like and I was happily surprised
by where his reason that yeah I thought
you did a terrific job especially
because like when we first meet him like
he's a bad situation
and then he becomes another vital part
of the operation and he's got some humor
but he's also got something to prove and
I thought you did a terrific job I mean
the answer is the character introduction
he's already suffering just for being
part of the Imperial Army he's trying to
do the right thing yeah and he's in any
suffering already so I thought it was
cool that we got to see that this guy
really he's not he's not like
second-guessing anything like he really
wants to do good this time yeah and I
think having him around did add more
personal effect from Mads Mikkelsen
because he does hook up the thing and
the ship to be able to trance transfer
the plants he does say it's for that
carriage you know and that was great I
love how we how much of a connection you
fell to that guy - I'm so thug - just at
last thing I want to say about dunya
when you can be more badass than a Jedi
with a stick
yeah that's pretty epic I mean his some
of this fight sequences with that stick
ready incredible some of the best fight
sequences ever ending in combat I've
ever seen in a Star Wars film so and I
like that they're bringing more of that
and like just kind of makes up for the
raid guys shut up and my god what a
waste so disappointed right no that's
what I meant by getting international
stars yeah they're not using them like
this makes higher Uniting every time G
Club yes this makes good use of
everything it has at its disposal and
that was one of my favorite moments
because that was like oh cool a new
brand of fighting in this Orlov yes what
other Easter eggs that we notice kgt
wants to know so grand moff tarkin don't
know if that's an easter egg we're
obviously r2d2 Nova Jimmy Smith oh they
lagana
we got no idea what he talks about
obi-wan yeah yeah and also - he's
literally talking about how he's about
to go back to Alderaan where we don't
he's about to be blown up by the Death
Star literally so I mean and Captain
America's shield is like oh yeah I did
notice that - and the Infinity Gauntlet
- him one of those other ships Thor's
Hammer's like on hey JJ it's all
connected we didn't burn their life
there was only one moment in the movie
where I felt like oh the stormtroopers
still sucking shooting it was it was
right before Jim did shoot the other k2
has so robotic yeah there's like
standing in this small moment either
stormtroopers on either side their
business thing for me about Star Wars
specifically this isn't like a good
criticism but like whenever I'm watching
one of these movies I always have like a
certain buffer zone or like okay I'll
allow some some crappy stormtroopers
because it's Star Wars time somebody's a
little bit stiff or like stormtroopers
can't
and also to did mention in a new hope
that I can barely see a thing in this
man so I had I was thinking about that
the whole day I was like half of these
people especially all these people who
are like dark space hallways with these
like you get a review I noticed two on
the beach when there's a mixture of
storm troopers sort of like really clean
different kind of rusty was just like a
rusty worn-out suit from battling or
something
actually that's some way those little
little flourishes I think those are
great where they have dirty storms
released yeah guys probably old around
Rome III should my thoughts on force
what if every shirt some of yours wiki
what did you guys actually think I saw I
thought it was I mean he was not bad but
if you watched by no means a standout
character I thought he was I thought it
would be more vital to the story and you
really I mean he was for the moment the
moments that he was in the movie but he
didn't play a bigger role yeah I thought
he was obviously gonna have a little
bigger world too but I mean he does set
jyn erso on it was evident yeah but it's
quick yeah because he's the one who's
telling jyn erso like you know when she
wants to just walk away from everything
you know like he's telling her that
there's something to fight in you know
and whatever and without giving a lot of
flashbacks and montages of stuff it's a
great explanation as to how jitters of
skill yeah he tried to be super menacing
like when he was trying to interrogate
the pilot yeah but it just I didn't feel
like that was too perfect I just kept
thinking of [ __ ] uh what's the movie
blue velvet base on this is a one-off
rogue one question we'll take but I just
think it would be a fun question what
moral superhero would you choose to
fight Baker if I want a good fight or if
I want to I feel like just use the time
gym like Doctor Strange is the only one
who has a chance of defeating
I watch dr. strange is Iron Man from a
distance you can't cheat
you have to take out his his
life-support system you know dr. strange
is the only one or scarlet which would
definitely win whereas like if you
fought Thor I think Thor could probably
hold his own but I'm not sure who is
that yeah oh my god odds Rock that was
what it's phasers but I feel like Thor
could at least give them a good
challenge they read a couple of
questions here we're gonna wrap this up
in about five or ten minutes guys how's
it feel for the rebellion I'm gonna try
read your question out loud how did it
feel for you that the rebellion only had
a vote to battle the Empire instead of
Jenna uh I was raised one of the best
things about the movie was I didn't miss
the Jedi surprising I thought like a
Star Wars movie without
well it could be a little bland but if
you look at a new hope obi-wan is like
people need shadow yeah because Luke
doesn't become a Jedi until Empire sorry
last thing I'll say because the reason
it's also like because that makes the
force even much more powerful like you
were saying earlier in terms of like a
spiritual aspect that the part of their
hope part of what it capsulate the hope
is their belief in the force and that's
what I love about the Star Wars films of
like good overcoming evil despite the
odds are up against yeah well this is
it's it's Star Wars and the thing is the
first the first saga of movies like
those are all you know are sort of the
gods of this story these are the people
who fought at the top and got it done
but every war has its people who are
fighting the battle after battle after
battle coming up with strategies doing
the important stuff because this needed
to happen and they're sneaking into you
know a place full of people who don't
all use the Force and stuff like those
are also obstacles of this world so for
me I I didn't miss the Jedi at all yeah
again I liked having them far off
because it it makes the universe more
expensive it justifies this movie's
existence they would disagree on that
like oh they're just going off the word
of this girl they don't have the force
to help them out here and did tell them
what to do they can really you know have
their faith you know in their hope
because it was at a time where they do
believe all the Jedi's were wiped out
yeah they feel more human I feel there's
not make the odds feel a lot more
impossible we actually brought the great
a great moment we're done ant except
that TIE fighter and it crashes into
that one with his like crust yeah that
was great because I I don't like you
when I see like action stars were known
for fight scenes like start using guns
and it doesn't look that cool but that
was a cool cool laser Pacific tech yeah
his even his blaster is specifically
yes exactly exactly and yeah like and he
uses it a few times and yeah when he
takes out that TIE fighter half of my
brain one really but the other half and
those wave things aren't that yeah hit
it in the right spot no I bought it for
sure and like you said it was just stuff
badass home and you bought it when it
happened rare gin guys oh yeah it's the
I think rain because you know that she
has a more key role I feel like in the
series going forward I actually liked
gin more than I was expecting to out of
Kyla from the trailers I'm like I don't
obviously don't think I'm going to like
this character but I liked hers but she
never really was she wasn't like super
stand out bad that her crew I thought I
had a more of an emotional pull towards
Ray just from her from performance what
I feel like there was more writing in a
full character invested in Jim but I
feel like with rain started preparing to
perform it's emotional it's different
characters which I liked
I like that like Oh carrying two Star
Wars movies were back-to-back the main
characters of female but they're very
different yeah he starts off strong she
starts off like I can kick ass yeah I
mean break a kid gasps - yeah mine was
right
yeah guys didn't catch the callbacks to
the old trilogy at the c-3po plugging
into the Imperial Death Star Destroyer
and a new boat and casting and shooting
at the storm troopers I'm realizing he
is outnumbered what like I think you
mean I mean the little thing we plugged
in like when when they got the Death
Star plans I do now remember they showed
a picture of the Dead or which is the
exact same picture that we see in a new
hope when they yeah I guess that's an
easter egg dude there's the base of the
rebel base I guess just now yeah before
I had the whole piece or wiki - I so
maybe for the purposes of this review
I'll join team Jin answer the rage in
question to go back a second like I'd
almost have to watch the force awakens
again yeah in trying to compare like
when you've just seen one movie and it's
been a while since I've seen force
awakens but yeah I'm just glad now we're
not gonna have a crazy debate about
whether she could fight the bad guy at
the end or not so that's gonna be that
wasn't ever seen the trailer were a
giant TIE fighter here's yeah I missing
the bridge is like right right there at
the time yeah I don't when she didn't I
don't think it was there was a few
things cut that I like I rebelled that
line was cut there was a few other shots
I think too there was a scene where
cretak is saying to me like you don't
understand the power or something like
that I remember that in trailer - I
didn't a lot of times I spliced lines
together like one of the cheesy lines
have on the trailer was when she says
rebellions old Bill Clinton I thought
that was so cheesy but the movie does a
great job of like yeah exactly it works
better in the whole context instead of
like slicing into the trailer moment
yeah let's see there's gonna get one
more question here let's see we need one
more cool questioners go back let's go
back to the beginning of this back to
the old school questions
shhh oh my god is silent in the
livestream I will say it will be cool
and when you do get this film on blu-ray
like to watch it back to back with you
know rogue one and then go right into
episode four yeah into the future where
the quality is something I would just
skip the previous two like well now have
said to me that kind of wants to watch
it again episode 3 usually my favorite
of the prequels but watching it recently
some of the seams are just so terrible
yeah acting like but they're all that
way I mean honestly like to is I don't
get the love story yeah you cut all the
love scenes out to choose decent but I
actually kind of want to make a semi
case from someone it's not as bad as
everyone thinks it is I think it is a
terrible moments but I provide raising
episode one is incredible the second
level place here at valves between
obi-wan and qui-gon and I wish they just
hadn't told off Darth Maul in this
episode - er than women okay kind of
phrase arc where we're kind of a phrase
dad shares question here did you guys
want to see the Emperor's I was
wondering if we were gonna see him at
one point it would be cool if we did but
I mean I would take it was already
gotten feet yeah but also to eight a new
hope we didn't see the embassy and we
get we heard but when grand moff tarkin
and Vader were coming into the meeting
where Vader chokes the guy I find your
lack of faith disturbing they were
talking about they just got off with the
with the Emperor so that might be
attributed in the same way because
there's we can only mentioned one time
and just movie too similar a similar way
to answer this question specifically
like I was never at any point watching
the movie right where's the Emperor like
I would like him but if he wasn't I
wouldn't yeah what did I claim could be
cool damn I'm across the line and
unnecessary yeah I feel like this
especially this pride like this is I get
the sense that this is Darth Vader's
yeah I think so the best start again
it's a scope thing where I think it got
tougher upper management and it doesn't
need to go higher yeah well movie
centers around the Death Star yeah but
really this will be don't man last
question remote and Unchained do you
want to see a war film or any film based
between Episode six and seven I think
that could actually be worthwhile
because if you look at the forum it's
all about force awakens if you look at
the flashbacks of all that [ __ ] I want
to see that yeah it's only hinted at and
I'm like that's kind of seems like there
was a whole movie there instead of what
we actually got in the force a week
there's like that might have been more
interesting in some ways to or I think
if they make it like they made this one
yeah by all means yeah yeah yes I
wouldn't be opposed to it I mean but
just from this sounds of everything I
mean we got the Han Solo anthology film
coming out in two years obviously we got
Episode eight next year then we got
Episode nine coming out after Han Solo
so I mean and then I believe they're
talking about doing an Obi one so uh the
film as well so I mean I be down for
that but I just don't know when they're
gonna exactly do it I wonder if they're
gonna ever really marble this out in
terms of light like they do a spin-off
movie that's not a pretty cool but takes
place let's say they're like did a Star
Wars movie after episode 7 and then
episode 8 has to work off of whatever
that was see where it was establishment
you know kind of like a peach Marvel
movie effects the next one yeah I'm
wondering if if if one day he'll get to
that I hope they do a little to Melia
but do you ever think they're gonna stop
never going to stop them during this
movie is is like a hit me clicked I was
like oh wait I can count on a Star Wars
movie every year now yeah but the reason
yes are good no and that's something
that again like they just they stuck the
landing at least for me with the force
awakens and this I'm at least right now
really enthusiastic about but I also
know these are just gonna continue
indefinitely and especially it's a
different kind of movie when you do a
han Solo solo film right so I'm still
curious about what they're gonna do and
I I don't really want them to do the
whole like everything's linear you've
got 12 of these eventually so I
understand like I said what I like so
much about this is it it's a different
story in the same universe the same
thing like Prometheus sounded awesome
cuz it wasn't going to be alien this is
awesome you know sort of because it
sticks that landing it doesn't force it
to be super relevant to them the other
movie yeah like you can watch a new hope
without having seen this and you'll
still enjoy it this just adds a little
more depth that adds a little more to
how they got like that little scroll
line that we saw
where the the rebels stole the dust our
plan it just had so much more oh yeah
that one little line you saw in the
opening Texan new hope so I mean again
it's not you don't have to watch this it
just adds more more depth it's that
little crawl line and when you go back
to fourth roots four through six at
least you have now you're like oh I have
even more stinks because of what I just
saw happened like this is also what
people have put their lives in the line
before and that makes those films that
much more I think are maybe just like
you can make as many Star Wars movies as
you want just care about the quality
that you put into each one what would
you make it everyone good and it's all
right yeah the third one needs to stick
it because we're still we're still
outnumbered by bad Star Wars retreading
yeah we're two to three now so we need a
third one to really make me go okay yeah
well I just this ship you know all right
this this for sure will be the final
question that was calling you tonight if
you were a character from rogue one
which character would suit your
personality the most great I'm more like
a to us my sarcasm yeah yeah great Greg
is our bodyguard yeah alright guys thank
you everyone who tuned in for our live
stream next live streams will not be as
some tunneled in terms of just road one
talk but thank you guys so much
make sure to subscribe to the real
rejects thank you for everyone on you
now we've donated bars Danny unchain one
Joshua Burford Stuart os-- I mean
knowledge earlier Stuart puri and one
Devin be leo and for Bello boat alia -
why do you guys donated bars thank you
so much so caught up in our talk they
get everyone on YouTube movie source
channel these mofos over here they do a
lot of great talk I'm sure
even after talking about Star Wars for
an hour and a half they're probably
gonna shoot their own video about it
anyway so go make sure to go check them
out and you guys have so social mediums
to use I know you add uses Twitter a lot
a core 711 and you can find me on
Twitter at Jaipur sweet thank you
everyone
you have a great night bye the force be
with you that's a divorce locking jaw
locking Jim okay